how're you guys doing today good good I
want to start by saying congratulations
on the movie it's just a tremendous film
and one of the things is I'm just gonna
start with the way it was shot which is
you guys used I believe 16 millimeter
IMAX talk a little bit about the
decisions on the format you wanted to
shoot with and you know let's start with
that I mean you know leanness and I are
right from the get-go I think talked
about just how can we make it feel as
immersive as possible how can we make
the audience feel like they're going on
these journeys with with Neil and and
also with Neil's family so we wanted to
shoot it like a documentary we wanted to
shoot it in a very up close and personal
way 16-millimeter was the format of
choice for the astronauts in space in
terms of their own coverage of their
missions so we modeled our look after
that after that archival footage and
then when it came time to finally land
on the moon
at the end of the film then I think we
wanted to try to make that into a Wizard
of Oz sort of moment where you can kind
of get that lift and that sense of
extremity from the tightest smallest
kind of claustrophobia you can imagine
to this vast expanse this cosmic sort of
achievement
so going from 69 max felt like a fun
kind of way to communicate that yeah and
the reason for 16 mil is really to be
you know emotional emotionally connected
with their characters we felt the 16
male is really beautiful and that's the
great thing with film formats is that
you can use this all various film
formats for expressing different parts
of the story and the story is so wide in
terms of dramatic scope so that it was
very it was really fun with this project
to to go from the very very intimate
close intimate you know photography with
the characters to the the wide space I
was gonna say yeah one of the things is
when you want to do so many close-ups
cuz the film does have so many close-ups
do you get like you have an amazing
track record but does the studio ever
look at the dailies and say wow that's a
lot of close-ups yeah I mean I think
they were look I think we were really
lucky to have a studio that backed a
whole host of somewhat unconventional
you know things that we wanted to try
with this not not the least the idea of
shooting a large portion of movie on 16
to begin with it's a lot it's just a
different sort of style than you usually
would use in a big movie like this but
also I think a lot of the approaches
Josh took to his script that Ryan took
to his performance that I linked took to
the sound design of the movie I think in
every case I think we wanted to try to
do something a little different you know
because there have been of course famous
movies about this era and famous
documentaries about this era and this
the moon Lane in itself is of course the
imagery of that is something we all grow
up with and think about all the time so
we wanted to try to make sure to strip
away the mythology get at a different
perspective on this and make it feel
like you had never seen it before
actually jump into the script real quick
about the story and these characters
that got you excited to you know want to
tell this story and also I don't want to
reveal anything but you show some things
in the movie that I didn't know and what
was it like learning some of these new
things for me yeah I think that that
that was the hope that hopefully we
would show a lot of things that people
didn't know you know I mean the first
attraction was you know I I literally
whiplash had just come out in Sundance
and I literally watched on a DVD before
it hit the theaters and was just totally
excited to work with this guy said where
whatever mission he's on I want to be on
that mission I didn't know much about
Neil Armstrong and you know what I knew
was sort of the bland iconography which
we all know what amazed me was when I
got into Jim Hansen's book how much
sacrifice loss and failure
there was over the course of this six
seven year span that really most people
don't know about it at all and it's sort
of that dovetailed nicely with Damian's
initial idea of showing how terrifying
this really was and how dangerous it was
well there were real dangers of real
losses you know in terms of life in
terms of some great heroes who we
forgotten like a Dwight and Nellie it's
see in Gus Grissom and and so really
detailing some of that I felt like would
expose a whole new edge to to NASA and
to the space program at the time which
would be very in some ways exciting in
terms of when we look at things that we
want to tackle in the future I think
it's good to know that it's hard that
it's ordinary people ordinary men and
women like Neil and Janet who are
sacrificing a ton in order to get there
one of the things I'm always curious
about is you're telling a very true
story but you're also making a movie so
talk a little bit about that line of did
you ever feel like well we're gonna have
to dramatic eyes you know like embellish
a little bit or is it always it has to
be accurate you know I mean I think we
wanted to you know there's it depends on
the style of movie of course with this
movie I think again going
to that documentary-style that real-time
immediate style we wanted to adopt I
think it was really important that it be
as truly authentic as possible that's
why it was such a joy to work with
someone like Josh who is just just goes
into the research to an extent and and
you want to say Anil here right right
OCD CJ gets so OCD and obsessive about
the research that nobody just grounds
everything and of course I mean we kept
finding stuff in the research that was
more sort of wild and shocking and
emotional and informative than stuff we
could have come up with anyway and
especially talking to people who lived
these times you know talking to Neal
sons Rick and Mark Neal's wife Janet
talking to astronauts who flew with Neil
like Dave Scott and Mike Collins and
Buzz Aldrin and people at NASA at the
time we were really lucky to just have
those doors open to us and be able to
spend real quality time with these
people and often have them come to set
so we could just make sure that we got
every you know down down to the down to
the nitty gritties that we could try to
get it as as accurate as we could one of
my first great mentors in writing I was
lawrence O'Donnell Jr who I wrote with
on the west wing and he early on said to
me well fact is always more interesting
in fiction than anything you can make up
and I think it's true
and that was sort of the general
approach we took here one thing that
we've done because we felt such
responsibility because I think we're
shedding real new light on an American
icon is we've written a book which is an
annotated screenplay where we have great
photos from the movie which shows off
the incredible work of Venus and Damian
but also really goes in detail in terms
of what's true and more detail on what's
true but also what's not true where we
fictionalized in why why we made those
decisions because I think in a film like
this that's always a difficult axis and
I've written you know this is my fourth
film trying to you know trying to work
work at that level and and and so I just
thought we should begin to have a
conversation about these things as
filmmakers so I hope that book well we
definitely have to talk about the sound
design because it's exceptional I it so
immersive talked a little bit about
just the genesis of how you got involved
in the project and also just the
challenges of trying to recreate all of
these sounds and and I'll stop there
okay well thanks thanks for the
compliments I'm glad you like it
well I got involved in the film because
I've worked with Damien on lala land
and once he brought us back on to work
on our first man yeah we start doing a
lot of research and going through some
NASA archives and stuff and so some of
the challenges you know as you can see
are know some of the cockpit scenes in
order to sell you know the danger that
the astronauts were going through you
know basically got in this like fragile
metal spacecraft so we started gathering
sounds recording sounds for it like the
sound of the saturn v to sell it no it
wasn't still as the most powerful rocket
in history and it's hard to get period
recordings from back then that are
really good quality so we just lucked
out this past February SpaceX launched
that like biggest rocket today
Falcon hey B and that's the closest in
size to it so we managed to record it
really close together mission to launch
the sonic booms for it that we used in
the next epstein sequence did SpaceX got
it thank you in the credits it did and
and plus like it was a record a few
other rockets like from Yali and some
other rocket companies in the Mojave
Desert so you know we have the sounds of
a thruster so also to feel the low-end
energy you know during the launches we
went to JPL and recorded you know that
acoustic test chambers where they used
to test hardware to simulate an actual
launch environment so it's like not
powered my natural nitrogen gas
and also you know down to like we wanted
to try to sell some of the authentic
audiences the city of it and so yeah so
some of the helmet error that you hear
in the movie were actually recordings of
the bubble helmet that like astronaut
John Young wore for the Apollo 16
mission which is the sound that you
worked on till the very very end that
you were never happy with though that's
a good question
well I don't know if I'm not never
really quite happy with but it's always
challenging you know it's during the
gemenese been you know because we have
to sell like you know how how out of
control and they were so close to like
dying and losing it during the spin and
so we had to create like this loop foot
spin and that was a little challenging
and so yeah so we had sounds that we
used like say like from training
coupling and all that but you know we
tried many different things but they
mean have a very specific idea and so
Justin Hurwitz came in to help also with
recreating it with like some musical
instruments that then I process it no
I'm distorted as it as if eiling's job
wasn't hard enough we brought in
officers of our consultants to watch the
film before picture lock we brought in
Frank Hughes and Joe angle the last x-15
living pilot we brought in Rick and Mark
Armstrong Mike Collins we had a ton of
experts come in and watch the film and
comment on everything from you know the
Gemini is missing a nose you know a
docking bar which we had to put in to
the sound and so we were getting it from
all sides you know it was like a month a
month in six weeks and so that's what
well yeah
had a good point about it for the Titan
miss Titan rocket which launched the
Germany that it makes this like unique
Titan like sound during intermission in
the chirp it's almost like a like a kind
of sound so we did some like research
and archives and some like news Rio's up
that with that sound and that it's only
unique to the Titan rocket so so we had
that in the movie too
during ignition for the Germany I'm
curious about how much with the way you
guys collaborate is it storyboards like
figuring everything out before you walk
on set
how much is it you know figuring it out
in the moment and how did it change from
lala land to this it's I mean it's a
combination I think de Muniz has very
much an idea in his head and works out
the story in the way of how you would
like to shoot it and in this case we had
to actually Damian had to do storyboards
for the entire all the space you know
travel just because also Damian really
wanted to make this film as realistic as
possible and therefore we wanted to
shoot the whole film very realistic so
we didn't use any green screen or we
didn't use all the visual effects was
created in pre-production in order for
us to actually shoot imagery on screen
huge LED screens that we projected on
and to do so we we put crafts on gimbals
and stuff that had us work very detailed
about like what angles were shooting
what day and and so on so we had to
Damon did a very meticulous like
storyboard and and previous of the space
travel
really and then we left more to to the
earth sort of a story to to work out
with actors together with actors how to
tell the story
I'm just gonna say I'm basically out of
time already so I'm just gonna do if I
know it went it's crazy my last thing
for you I always ask you this how long
was your first cut compared to the
finished film first cut was well they
you know that this wasn't actually too
out of control it was about two hours
and 35 minutes and without credits
finished film is 2 hours 15 I think
that's actually really that's pretty
tight yeah I remember when Josh saw the
first cut of me he and he had a good
point he realized that we had actually
in order to get to that 2 hours and 35
minutes we'd basically gutted the first
act and so we actually wound up
restoring a lot of stuff while
tightening other stuff so it's always
this kind of you know it's it's that's
kind of what I love about editing too is
is is you never really know exactly
where you're going to wind up and you
sort of are casting darts in the dark
and then you're finding your way through
yeah it's also the final rewrite so you
know oh it's a I listen I have a million
other questions but you have to do what
we call some premiere you know like or
introduced you know you know nothing
important
so I'll just say that to be continued
because I have a million other questions
before we go I messed up at the
beginning the only reason I get to do
these interviews is cuz of house of
Aurora I partnered up with them they're
the sponsor and I want to give them a
huge thank you house of Aurora thank you
thank you all so much for coming in
movies fantastic for having thank you
you